in South Bend Indiana Davis weathers hey
Dave your question for Rachel and me hi
guys thanks for taking my call sure my
question is about the debt snowball my
wife and I are just beginning our debt
snowball and I have a $35,000 student
loan that we're trying to figure out
where to put into the snowball snowball
work you tell me well Mike I know how
the snowball works but the reason why I
have the question on it is because
within that thirty five thousand there
are multiple loans that make up that
thirty five thousand you don't you don't
have a thirty five thousand dollar loan
you have multiple loans okay so put them
in in the orderliness on the smaller
loans that's what we do yeah okay Rachel
what do you think yeah that's exactly
right and I love the fact that you have
separate loans honestly just because of
the motivation of paying it off quickly
because I do know people that have a
30,000 you know a $35,000 loan and it
just takes so long to climb the mountain
and get over it so the fact that it is
broken up honestly is probably to your
advantage it's not mathematically
speaking but just behavior change wise
because you're gonna be able to knock
them out faster and it's gonna keep you
more motivated great thank you very much
you get to ring the bell more times and
more you ring the bell the more pumped
you get yeah and it's the one type of
debts that we're okay with you
consolidating but you can only
consolidate student loans once but
that's the negative factor again is that
if you consolidate it becomes one huge
loan and it's gonna take you much longer
to pay that off so having them separated
and broken up honestly it's gonna
probably do anymore
usually when you can saw that does not
save you much interest now it's usually
not worth fooling with so yeah I would
just I would lay them out in order in
the debt snowball break them up they are
broken up but just use the just you use
the idea that they were gonna put them
in the order based on their current size
not based on the category of student
loans yeah be like if I had four car
loans well we would break them up with
you we wouldn't say one big car loan
we'd say four different loans and and
the beauty of that again is what
Rachel's pointing out the behavior
you're going to get to accept that hey
you guys very song crews here
hope you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show if you didn't know I actually have
my own YouTube channel so I had to do
videos twice a week on life and money so
you can click the subscribe button to
subscribe to my channel and if you want
to check out our video right now check
out the video on how to make a budget